(soft music)
(upbeat music)
- Hey, come on in.
Yes, Push and
Believe, you got it.
Jared, before we go on any
further, I'm a classy guy,
would you like some coffee?
- I would, yeah.
- Okay, here we go,
I'll do a little here.
- Just out of a,
- You know this is gourmet
coffee, we'll go ahead and pour
that for you.
- Just out of a,
- It's just a local bodego
that I researched on Yelp.
- Okay.
- I'm gonna actually add
a little more.
(whimsical music)
So Jared, tell me a
little bit about yourself.
You are from West Virginia,
- Yes.
- And we'll start with
that, take it from there.
- I'm from West Virginia.
- I'm thinking of two names
right now from West Virginia.
Think of the names that
I'm visualizing in my head.
- Chris.
- Caris?
- Chris O' Donnell.
- Chris O' Donnell?
- Is that right?
- I was not thinking
of Chris O'Donnell.
- Okay.
- Where'd you go to college?
- I went to, it's a school,
- I've heard of it.
- It's known for
their theater program.
- You got it.
- They're also known for all
of from their classics program.
- Juliard.
- No, the University
of Memphis.
- Jared I read on your
bio that you're an artist,
you like to doodle, you
like to sketch and things
of that nature, I want
you to doodle me, draw me,
and I'm gonna try and draw you.
- That's great.
- And let's see what happens,
in fact, I have the materials
available,
- Very good.
- So now we have two pieces
of paper and we are ready.
- Well we need something
that makes a mark.
- Okay, I thought you
were a finger paint guy.
I actually have a couple jumbo,
permanent,
- Perfect.
- Okay, sketch each other now.
- I already started.
- Okay.
- Just to be honest.
- Okay, you're quick,
he's been in this business
for a while.
(Jared chuckles)
I need to look at your
ear a little, okay.
- Whatever you need to do.
- I hear you're into, you
know, Dungeons and Dragons.
- Yeah, a little bit of
that, yeah we do a little bit
of that.
- Can you smile for me?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- I'm excited for
you to see this.
- Alright, well I'm pretty
much done, I'm ready to,
you know I have a joke and
I may use it on my half hour
special, I am such not a
draw, artists in Times Square
refuse to sketch me.
I am such not a draw artists,
- I'm such not a draw,
- In Times Square
refuse to sketch me.
- That is,
- It's one of my bits,
and it could be closure
on my half hour special.
I'll reveal mine to you.
- I hope it's not.
Okay go ahead.
- This is mine.
Boom, right there.
- That's good.
- Okay, so that's you.
- I think I have thicker arms.
- I gave you nice teeth, I
gave you hashtag West Virginia.
- Mine's, this is, I think
you're gonna really like,
you're gonna want to put
this up like over your bed,
I'm serious.
What do you think?
- Wow.
That is pretty good.
Kind of made my nose pointy,
kind of like a Freddy Krueger.
- I draw what I see.
- Well I guess you see my
nose touching my lip, I mean,
it's kind of a hook nose.
- What's that?
- That's just like kind
of your forehead wrinkles.
- What's that stubble on my?
- That's the, that's how,
like, your hair starts like,
at the very top of your head.
- You saying I'm balding?
I used to have a lot of hair.
- No, I'm just saying that,
- Let's check them out with
each other.
- Yeah, I love it.
- Jared Logan, Brody Stevens,
bringing it for Comedy Central
we are kindred souls,
and we're ready,
- Yeah.
- Let's try that again.
- Yes, Push, Believe,
- Push, Believe.
- You got it, crushing it,
warm ups for live, blood oath.
Woo.
Thanks Jared.
- Thanks man.
- If you like the video,
Tweet me at Brodyismefriend.
Let's go viral.
Let's break records.
Let's put me on the map,
with the help of you.
Got something to say?
Leave me a comment
because I'm reading them.
Let's see that view count
higher, it's like a telethon,
you're helping out Brody's kids.
Brody's gotta eat.
We can do it together.
Push & Believe.
Hashtag yes.
(gurgles)